We now have first person intel from inside the
westview anomaly what are we looking at here is
it an alternate reality time travel it's a sitcom
starring two avengers that's a working theory
life moves fast out in the suburbs
i think something's wrong here
should we just take it from the top
i don't know how any of this
started what is outside of westfield
yeah i'm not sure what that's about it's
probably just a case of the mondays am I right
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision episode 5 trailer video there's a
whole bunch of stuff explaining what's going on
the next couple of episodes so we'll break it
all down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs as well if you're brand new to the
channel i'm doing videos for all the Wandavision
episodes be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're still doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just post all your theories in
the comments below it is only going to get crazier
as we go forward as the trailer footage implies
but careful for spoilers if you haven't seen any
of the episodes yet we'll just go through this
shot by shot and then i'll explain some of the
other big theories too like i know everyone's
still asking about the hexagons and what's
going on with the larger cosmic characters don't
worry we'll cover all that stuff but the trailer
starts with the tyler hayward director of sword
character briefing the other agents about the
situation after having recovered monica rambo
at the end of episode 4 she's the person he's
referring to when he says that they now have
first person intel from inside the barrier
notice behind them on all the monitors they've
already changed to the 1980s they've moved forward
in the timeline and inside the alternate house of
m reality they're in the middle of this scene from
the other trailers where agnes comes in in the
workout gear the 80s looking workout gear and says
they have to redo a scene like hey should we just
take it from the top it just completely shocks
scarlet witch when she seemingly realizes that
agnes knows about her rewinding time every time
something crazy happens that she doesn't like like
any time vision seems like he's starting to figure
out what's really going on something's wrong here
like nope nope we don't want him to find out that
he's actually still dead but it does seem like
agnes knows what scarlet witch is doing when
she rewinds time even though when she was talking
to herb earlier it didn't seem totally like that
i'll talk about this in greater detail in just
a second but it seems like some of the people
inside the town know what's happening to them that
they're trapped like herb knows that he's trapped
that's why he's cutting through the barrier trying
to get out but also agnes or agatha harkness seems
like she knows even more about it than the
others do then they're giving monica rambo a
full medical exam inside a containment area like
they're not totally sure what happened to her
while she was in the middle of going all stepford
wives through the decades because as we saw for a
brief period her mind also succumbed to scarlet
witch's influence and she believed that she was
the geraldine character it was until crazy things
and loud noises like really really things happened
that kind of shook her out of that and she
started to remember who she was and where she was
without more evidence right now my theory is
is the reason why some of the towns people like
dottie for instance has the same moment like
that when something crazy happens it kind of
shakes her and she's like wait a minute who are
you what am i doing here she kind of realizes
what's happening the reason why some of the towns
people who we know are mostly just normal citizens
of the united states living in west view new
jersey before scarlet witch came along why they're
able to shake the influence is probably because
they have stronger wills than some of the other
people it probably has something to do with that
it's the same thing with odin and loki during thor
ragnarok like he says it took him a while to shake
loki's magic trick that he pulled on him to make
him believe that he was a homeless person like
your mother would have been very impressed with
that magic spell you put on me it took me quite
a while to get rid of it like if doctor strange
got trapped inside the house of m alternate
reality if he got sucked into the scenario
he would also probably figure out pretty quickly
what was going on just because he's so powerful
then jimmy wu is questioning the nature of the
phenomenon is it multiverse is this an alternate
reality is it time travel because those are twists
that they just used in avengers end game with the
quantum realm in alternate timelines darcy gives
the more practical answer it's a sitcom and then
you know they just make the joke about starring
two avengers really it's meant to be a combination
of those different twists not time travel in
the traditional sense but scarlet witch has
been shown to control the flow of time rewinding
things like you would a vcr tape and speeding
up the flow of time through the future decades but
then you see them in full 80s attire in the park
in front of the westview library then scarlett
witch has the voiceover talking about how life
moves really fast out in the suburbs literally
and metaphorically because of what's happening
during the series so it's a meta reference to the
quick pace with which they're moving through the
different decades episode to episode even though
they did break that a little bit during episode
4 the storytelling format because episode 4
was basically them just replaying the events
of the first three episodes but from monica rambo
and sora's perspective in the normal mcu world
starting with episode 5 though next week it seems
like they'll be moving forward at least one decade
in each new episode the 80s 90s 2000s than present
day while also bouncing back and forth between
sword people outside in scarlet witch vision
in their children the townspeople on the inside
this scene could still be during the 80s or during
the 90s it looks a little bit more like the 90s
just based on all the design and their clothing
but i think they're blending a lot of footage
from different future episodes in this trailer so
it could be footage from the 90s episode as well
it looks like she's just picking things up all
over the house you have the kids toys behind
her billy and tommy wicking and speed we'll see
toddler and older versions of them through each
of the episodes like much older speaking parts
they'll cast different child actors to play them
then you see vision in the halloween episode
which i believe is supposed to be the 90s episode
that might be episode 6 walking through the suburb
streets as she talks about life moving really fast
in the suburbs with kids and families dressed up
everywhere running around he's in the halloween
version of his classic comic book costume just
like scarlet witch i can't wait to see that vision
starts to notice that things are glitching out
something is wrong then you have that voiceover
dialogue i think that something is wrong here it's
just another version of the conversation that they
kept trying to have in the last couple of episodes
before she rewinds things like oh no he's starting
to figure it out it seems like the glitches start
to get worse and worse and worse as scarlet witch
starts to lose control of what's going on losing
control of her mental state her mental health
starts to deteriorate but also things start to get
weirder and crazier and crazier there have been
some leaks recently about stuff that happens in
the next couple of episodes so please don't post
spoilers about that in the comments below we're
only going to have to wait like a week or two to
get that stuff anyway so it's not like we're going
to have to wait forever to talk about it those big
surprises then in a separate scene scarlet witch
is speaking to vision or someone else saying that
she doesn't know how any of this craziness with
the sitcom started and it sounds like she's being
truthful like she doesn't understand how her
cosmic powers work or anything about the relic
cosmic radiation background effects the same type
of energy as the big bang tied to her ability to
create things and change things out of thin air
basically the mcu version of her reality warping
powers in the comics that also gets back to the
infinity stones and how her power is connected to
them the way that the infinity stones manipulate
the same type of cosmic energy to do what they do
altering the universe when people wield them this
is obviously just connecting things back to her
origin story the mind stone unlocking her powers
then you see the scenes from her in more modern
day settings of her messing with everything in
the living room it looks kind of like the modern
family episode when she's talking to the camera
of her in the pajamas talk about a case of the
mondays that's probably one of the funnier lines
for any of the trailers like she's talking about
crazy battles and things going off the rails
and she's trying to pass it off like she's
totally fine even though it's clear that she's
deteriorating mentally and she just calls it a
case of the mondays then you see separate really
scenes of vision pushing his weight like tearing
his way through the barrier outside westview
being able to make contact with the sword agents
this raises a really huge question what happens
to vision when he goes outside the barrier because
scarlet witch created the other things that have
survived outside from nothing or it involved
people who were still alive vision is technically
still dead like we make the weekend of bernie's
jokes like she's just walking around with a dead
vision animating his corpse kind of re-skinning
him she didn't really bring him back to life in
the same way she didn't create a brand new vision
this is the old vision and he's technically still
dead so early theory i think that's why at the end
of the series why her children will still be able
to survive outside but vision might not be able
to survive after the end of Wandavision after this
all collapses and that's probably just because of
the way she brought him back versus the way that
she created the other things out of nothingness so
we'll have to wait for the next couple of episodes
before we have a better theory about what happens
to vision after this i have better theories about
the kids than i do about vision but i do think
that the idea is that she'll have to say goodbye
to vision but she'll be able to keep the children
like the whole series is about her getting
over vision's death that's the whole reason
why she's doing all this because she just can't
deal with it so her arc in the series is she's
able to complete her hero's journey so to speak
she would eventually accept his death by the end
then there's another scene of vision flying off in
his normal avengers costume in broad daylight like
they're heading into battle scarlet witch and her
modern day sweats just unleashing this huge blast
of energy at someone then a completely separate
scene of a giant wave of her red energy changing
everything in the town from black and white 1950s
looking to color in modern day looking the way
they presented her changing reality it seems more
like a wipe transition like at the end of episode
2 but this might just be what it looks like for a
normal person outside the barrier if they were to
see her changing everything through the decades
like a giant wave of energy you also notice in
the later footage the exterior of the dome becomes
visible it turns red crackling with energy whereas
in the earlier episodes it's completely invisible
then you see the scene of her and her modern day
avengers costume flying inside what seems like
some sort of high-tech facility hard to tell if
this scene is a flashback happening before the
events of episode 1 or it's from the future and
it's happening after the next couple of episodes
but i know you have all kinds of questions about
some of the easter eggs that have popped up in the
last episode especially the hexagons because the
hexagons show up everywhere they're wondering
about why scarlet witch's barrier around her
alternate reality is a hexagon shape but the sword
base itself is a hexagon structure and if you look
at nick fury in the sword space station with all
the squirrels technology there are hexagons on
the screen behind him too and you keep in mind
too that this is happening on Wandavision three
weeks after avengers end game in spider-man far
from home this nick fury post credit scene is
happening eight months after avengers end game so
spider-man far from home this nick fury scene is
happening well after what happens on Wandavision
the whole idea with the hexagons and i'll probably
talk about this more in some of my other bonus
videos when we see more easter eggs for it the
hexagon itself is a naturally occurring phenomenon
and the reason why this is probably a hexagon is
because it's one of the strongest structures in
nature it's also the most efficient structure
in nature which is why you see it occurring
naturally so many places i think there's this
concept called the honeycomb conjecture like why
do bees honeycombs have hexagon structures instead
of some other shape because technically a triangle
would be the strongest shape but a hexagon is made
up of a bunch of triangles effectively the reason
why it is is because mathematically it's been
proven that the hexagon is the most efficient
structure like even in the sanctum when doctor
strange is studying all those magical tones
you notice that the bookshelves are honeycomb
structured that's because it's the most efficient
structure but it's also one of the strongest
structures in nature so i think low-key the reason
why they're looking at her barrier here and it's
a hexagon is because it's just naturally the
strongest structure and also when you see the
guardians of the galaxy ship in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 traveling through the different jump
gates it also turns into a hexagon looking barrier
it's a naturally occurring phenomenon it's just
because that's the most efficient and strongest
structure naturally occurring like they're trying
to say that scarlet witch's dome here like the
special bubble around her alternate reality
house of m is meant to be almost impregnable
but what will happen is i have a couple other
big bonus videos there's some cool fantastic four
easter eggs during episode 4 i'll talk about those
this weekend there's a whole bunch of stuff coming
up so leave all your requests for bonus videos in
the comments below my full episode 5 video will
post next friday just like normal everyone click
here for my full Wandavision episode 4 video and
click here for my Wandavision doctor strange video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!